[Musik]
hey was geht ab und willkommen beim ein
video jahr weiter heute geht es um
folgendes und war hab ich irgendwie
heute einen instagram account von mir
gefunden der etwa 45 jahre alt ich habe
mich auch gewundert hat ist vor fünf
jahren zu münster gab oder vor vier
jahren und da sieht man mich ruhig noch
etwas kleiner war und darf ich auf die
idee gekommen
zeig doch mal diese nennt er am account
und bin noch auf eine andere idee
gekommen und zwar wie sagen eigentlich
andere youtuber 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 jahres
oder so und bin einfach hingegangen
hatte google bilder angeschaut und ich
habe so witzige bilder wurden wo ich mir
das alter häftling jetzt den heutigen
video in youtube wie sie aussahen
bevor sie berühmt wurden ja und wenn ihr
bock habt auch das video wo ich einfach
mal meine alten instagram account zeige
weiterhin zu komische luftige gestörten
bilder drauf wo ich weiß nicht was ich
da zum teil einfach für sachen anhatte
wenn ich darüber auch mal wieder machen
weil wo ich euch den flakons und
bisschen feige lasst einfach nach oben
da sozusagen bei 12.000 leicht ist das
machbar
dann wird das video nächste woche folgen
arbeitsfähig gar nicht lang lagern
wir fangen einfach mal alles okay
vielleicht ein kleiner vorgeschmack so
sah ich aus vor fünf jahren
das ist wichtig schon fünf jahre her ich
glaube ich war da 13
das ist aber auch wirklich das beste
bild was ist so von damals von meggitt
über diesem bild was auch wirklich zu
zwei jahre so auf facebook unterwegs
weil ich wirklich so stark dass dieses
bild war für mich ja auch echt klub wie
es gibt viele alte bilder wo ich mir
denke eine lex aber bei diesem wetter
könnte ich mir so ein bisschen so zu
machen will wir würden ja leute also so
sah ich aus und jetzt passt zwar auf ich
hab mir fünf youtuber rausgesucht ich
hoffe wenn jetzt der ein oder andere von
euch dass ihr sie weckt sich selber wenn
ich euch im video haben mit diesem bild
was vielleicht nicht ganz so eurem
heutigen ausgeht entspricht anfang an
mit dem bild von okay leute ich musste
auch wirklich zweimal hingucken klar
wann er kindes so auf den ersten blick
eventuell wenn man die öfter warschau
oder wenn man fan von ihr
aber das ist einfach für ihn davis mit
acht neun oder so ich bin voll hässlich
weil ich mein gebieter aus wiesen klar
jeder warten ganz normaler teenager die
sie tätig ausgesandt kleines kind so
wovon man island erwartet dass die
irgendwann mal so aussieht wie sie heute
aussieht oder ich finde dass bei ihre
ich mit einem klassischen ich glaube
auch für ihn ist nur ein künstler aber
bei da wie die wirklich überhaupt nicht
aus wie ne für ihn
ich bin nämlich leider ich kann läuten
wenn ich sie nur sehe da kann ich schon
sagen wie sie hätten sofort klein auf
als architekt schon seiner funktion ich
hab gesagt hey das ist eine sohn nur
unter filmte wirklich obwohl ich den
namen gar nicht kannte und ich finde für
ihn sieht aus wie ne mit wissen selber
noch kurz gucken ich finde die sich aus
liebe elena könnt ihr das auch einfach
du leuten anhand ihres outfits zunahm
geben der so fasst zutrifft oder accum
egal wir machen weiter und zwar mit
diesem bild hier verrät so vom gericht
herz ist eigentlich nicht viel getan
aber die haare sind einfach mega land
bei ihm kann ich natürlich meine meinung
sagen erst sich auf jeden fall du warst
ein äußerliches angeht ins positiv
entwickelt meiner meinung also ja
irgendwie heutzutage wie das alles so
ein bisschen das passt zu mehr zusammen
als auf diesem foto klar das kann auch
daran liegen weil man so sein jetziges
außerdem ein bisschen getötet wenn er ab
und zu mal wieder auf meiner startet
lange dort wo ich mir das eigentlich an
so machen wir weiter ich hoffe ihr seid
mir nicht böse und zwar heiko und robert
m
dieses bild habe ich auch gefunden ich
habe das auch schon mal irgendwo gesehen
das ist ja normal dass so viele früher
immer noch ähnlich aussahen ich kenne
die beiden ja mittlerweile eigentlich
ziemlich gut aber ich kann euch da auf
keinen fall unterschiedlich hat keine
arme mehr wert ich würd mal sagen im
frühling erst mal angucken absolut kein
plan ist wird er sagen rechtes und
linkes roman oder das ist einfach nur
einer von beiden der halt nochmal
gespiegelt wurde das kann auch sag mir
bitte nicht böse dass ich das jetzt in
meinem video verwendet habe
wir machen weiter und war auch ziemlich
guter kollege von mir dass ich habe
diese filter facebook gefunden ich wette
das bild kennt eigentlich niemand hat
niemand so gesehen und er wieder einfach
auch aus wie der grösste was ist das
bitte schön wild ehrlich was ist es ich
finde es geil vor allem kennt die das
früher so von facebook man hatte immer
auf die bilder etwas drauf geschrieben
mit der adobe labs glaube ich fotos gelb
oder so einfach du hässlich sein namen
drauf mit dem umriss und so etwas ja
auch gemacht einfach mega keine fotos
wird auch mal sagen wird bestimmt sechs
sieben acht jahre her oder so schick mir
auf jeden fall auch mal bilder von
weiteren youtube sowie wie früher
ausland wenn ihr bock habt dass ich im
zweiten teil hiervon mache dann läuft es
auf jeden fall aber jetzt kommen wir zu
einem foto ruhig noch weniger drauf klar
komme ohne schein ändert ist einfach so
ein bisschen natürlich auch die zeit
aber auch für der einfluss von
bekanntheit somit person macht ich werde
nämlich während überhaupt nicht bekannt
würden wir heute total anders aus sie
geradeaus gehen natürlich jetzt gar
nicht negativ gemeint oder so aber keine
ahnung verfestigt und zwar musste ich
hier auch zweimal hingucken
wir haben ihre julia encke und viwis
beauty panel wenn man das bild noch nie
gesehen hat man längst zu und ich finde
auch wirklich cool dass ich schon so
lange zusammen sind das einfach
betrinken durch team für die da jetzt
mal auf entsetzen vielleicht 18
vielleicht war das auch wegen der party
und der julian hat etwas zu viel
getrunken
ich weiß es nicht aber die frisur hat
einiges raus und wenn man den heutigen
vergleich herstellt ich fünf hätte sich
wirklich mega kraft also meine
veränderung ich kann auch sagen hätte
ich nie mit youtube angefangen mit
diesem ganzen jahr ins da bleibe war das
sind dass ich kann offen sagen ich hab
mein kleidungsstil und so was alles das
wird so heftig durch youtube beeinflusst
man kommt einfach so da rein und ja man
interessiert sich irgendwie einfach mehr
dafür für sein äußeres kann ich bei mir
zu sagen seitdem ich youtube mache ist
das irgendwie so das kann man jetzt
positiv und negativ sehen aber ich finde
meine veränderung gar nicht nur kraft
also dass hier für mich heute wirklich
heftige veränderung kann
einfach mal so sagen ihr könnt ihr mal
schreiben in die kommentare wie findet
ihr das bild im vergleich zu erdgas ist
oder sich jetzt immer noch ganz gut aus
ansonsten findet wieder ausgefallen als
dann nach oben da für diese center video
dafür bitte ich bin gespannt und wir
sehen uns am montag wieder haut rein
erfolgt natürlich auf infrage man
skeptisch